haha the Joe Rogan experience did you
did you see did you watch - Jordan
knock-knock did you know my dad a watch
to tell me that no you have to know I
have to you have to watch listen you
because he's he's an alien he's one of
us
he's one of he's one of those aliens the
other aliens identify with and for
people listening me when i say alien she
knows the metaphor people that doesn't
mean a bit [ __ ] embracing aliens here
i get so much [ __ ] for everything it's a
metaphor okay but he he's different he's
[ __ ] different and what this shows
you is how different MJ was that man was
a [ __ ] winner he was a winner and and
that's that's it like that's it MJ one
there was no there is no other
conversation when you watch this doc and
you watch how he approached his days and
why he approached it and the things that
he did and his reason for doing them and
ultimately what he wanted and what his
priority and what his goals were you go
[ __ ] he did it we know why he did it
it's not a coincidence that he's a
champion it's destiny he there was no
other option it was champion or bus
there was no 600 vp's all-star and these
defense played here and you know most
likable player in the league and most
marketable no no if it's not a champion
attached to my name with several [ __ ]
trophies attacked there is no other
conversations and you [ __ ]
around me if you do not understand
and why I am the way I am then this is
not the place for you
do your job I've never heard Michael
Jordan talked the way the documentary
showed him talk do your [ __ ] job when
I pass you the ball hit the [ __ ] shot
that person now has to get better hmm
because I'm so nervous that it might
pass me to bar not miss this [ __ ]
shot I'm never going to get a shot again
yeah do your [ __ ] job when Mike is
talking to you like that I thought we
was just playing basketball I thought I
was out here having a good time
oh wait this is my job this is my
profession I'm supposed to do this this
and this if I don't do this I'm failing
at my job
you see these players today and you see
the way that they are I promise you man
rest in peace Kobe Bryant every bit of
the same they give my god LJ flak and
[ __ ] I promise you LeBron James is
nothing short of that I promise you
these people that are winning [ __ ]
win because there is no other option you
have to watch this doc and Joe you got
to text me after okay text me after and
just go holy [ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] man
I get it keV and the fuel that you're
talking about and that meter I promise
you your meter [ __ ] you I got it after
the day I got up [ __ ] over here was in
the dock let me think of what the next
thing is it instantly yeah instantly
fuel fuel instant fuel
[Applause]